las imágenes de soldados en las calles
de mianmar han traído al presente los
recuerdos del pasado la historia de este
país del sudeste asiático ha estado
ligada al poder armado durante décadas
una serie de militares comentaron el
estado y reprimieron con dureza
cualquier tipo de disidencia política
llegando a usar la tortura y el
asesinato como método disuasorio estos
40 años de dictadura militar en miramar
éste causaron serios y gravísimas
violaciones a derechos humanos
recordemos que el llamar se cometió
además el genocidio contra los rohingyas
con lo cual hay un récord de violaciones
de derechos humanos muy muy graves
incluida la detención de presos
políticos los intentos de democratizar
el país han sido siempre delimitados por
una élite armada reacia a dejar el poder
en 1988 miles de estudiantes y monjes
budistas se levantaron contra la junta
militar existente pero los militares
consiguieron imponerse de nuevo y aunque
en 1990 convocaron elecciones no
reconocieron la victoria de la liga
nacional por la democracia de aung san
suu kyi tras ver en peligro su poder la
violencia contra opositores aumentó
miles fueron detenidos y succi estuvo en
prisión domiciliaría durante
años hasta que en 2010 fue liberada no
es suficiente no pertenecemos a este
movimiento por la democracia para
defender una sola persona esto es para
todos y yo no veo por qué no podemos
reconciliarnos
a pesar de la llegada de la democracia
durante la última década los militares
siguieron manteniendo su poder en la
sombra y tras el golpe del 1 de febrero
pusieron fin de nuevo a los intentos de
democratizar el país